[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Please, let's
put our hands together
for William Winkel.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
WILLIAM WINKEL: Thank you
all for being here today.
My presentation is
called, "Myth of the Model
City, the Uprising of 1967."
I'm sure many of you have heard
about the anniversary of '67,
especially given
all the events that
are going on in the
city in the past year.
And the purpose of this talk is
to really flesh out and present
a nuanced view of
what took place
and why what took
place happened.
Given the amount if
time I have, we're
going to be starting in the
'60s, fresh off the bat.
Then we're going to backtrack
to see what led into '67.
Going into the
mid-1960s, Detroit
seemed happy, healthy,
and progressive.
In 1964, the "Wall
Street Journal"
proclaimed Detroit to be a
model city on race relations.
They said, if you need to have a
high-functioning, diverse urban
area, look at Detroit.
They know what they're doing
and they're doing it right.
One of the reasons why
we got that moniker
was this march in
the background here.
In 1963, 125,000 Detroiters
marched on Woodward
behind Martin Luther King,
Jr., Rev. C.L. Franklin,
Walter Reuther, and
Mayor Jerome Cavanagh,
in what was the largest
civil rights demonstration
up until that time.
The march was capped with
King's first iteration
of his "I Have a Dream" speech,
and it was a real feather
in the cap for the city.
The city was seemingly
progressive, powerful,
and moving forward
and acting as a leader
in terms of race relations.
The city at the time was
still the fifth largest city
in the country.
We've got 1.67 million people.
We are still well-regarded
as the arsenal of democracy,
but the city was changing.
We were becoming the Motor City
that didn't make cars anymore.
One of the main changes
for us was our leadership.
Right around the
mid-1960s was when
we see the final
shifts between the two
major political parties.
The two parties spent the last
30 years changing platforms,
and this is when we
see the cementing
of Detroit's now-current
political structure.
Mayor Jerome Cavanagh
was the first
in a long line of
Democratic leadership
that exists to today.
He was a break in
tradition in a lot of ways.
He was young, he was energetic,
and he was a Democrat.
Detroit had a long line
of Republican leadership
up until Cavanagh.
He's primarily known for
trying to do three things.
Bring in-- [INAUDIBLE]
money into the inner city,
clean up and integrate the
Detroit Police Department,
and clashing with Mexico City
to get the 1960 Olympics.
It can be argued he
failed at doing all three.
Detroit was on the up-and-up.
We weren't having
the same issues
that many other
cities were facing.
Rochester, Harlem,
and Philadelphia
were currently on fire.
Civic upheaval and
civic unrest seemed
to be a national
issue that Detroit
was sidestepping miraculously.
As a result, many people
started to look at us
and look at us closely, but
many, many things were missed.
What we're looking at right
here is a demographics map
of Detroit from 1960.
The dark colored-in areas
are where people of color
were allowed to live in Detroit.
The clear areas of
the map are where
the white community lived.
A couple of you may
have noticed that I just
said where people of color were
allowed to live in the city.
Detroit was an extremely
segregated city
with staunchly
defended neighborhoods
and the organization
to back that up.
Further complicating
the model city moniker
are these two maps right here.
The top one is employment
and the bottom one
is deteriorated or
dilapidated housing.
As you can see, these
two issues largely
correspond to where people of
color live, and only routinely
effect communities of color.
The white community
largely do not
have to deal with
these issues en masse.
Furthermore, despite the
fact that the Detroit Police
Department had 4,300 officers,
only 143 of those officers
were black.
95% of the police force was
white, and the majority of that
was Southern white.
Many recent arrivals from the
South in the last 30 years,
bringing with them Jim Crow
and other prejudices that
were a problem in the South.
Don't get me wrong, Detroit
had plenty of racists before,
but bringing with
them a fresh energy.
Furthermore, with that
discrepancy in numbers,
the Detroit Police
Department engaged
in routinely aggressive
tactics towards the inner city
community.
The two primary
tactics the police used
were called the big four
and investigative arrests.
Many people point to and talk
about stress during this time.
The stress wouldn't come till
the late 1960s, early '70s.
The big four were
four officers--
one uniformed, three
plainclothes officers--
that would drive around in
a four-door unmarked sedan.
Their catchphrase was,
"Give me the corner."
That was their catchphrase
because, in these areas where
people of color lived, they
were densely, densely packed.
Many of these areas,
while they did have homes,
the homes were
subdivided, meaning
that instead of a single
family living in a home,
there was either two or four
families living in that home,
and there were
apartment buildings.
Given the high
population density,
there wasn't a lot of space
to hang out with your friends.
As a result, many people
hung out on the street.
They hung out on
the street corners
relaxing and just chatting.
Many Motown singers actually
got their start singing
on street corners.
So when the big
four pulled up, they
said, "Give me the corner."
If you didn't, you were either
beaten, arrested, or both.
Sometimes, they would
make a game out of it
and they would say,
if you're still
standing here by the time
I drive around the block,
you're in trouble.
Stuff like that.
Additionally, the
Detroit Police Department
would conduct
investigative arrests.
They would pick
people on suspicion
of having committed a crime.
The crime could be
as small as numbers
running or pickpocketing,
or as high as murder.
What they would do is,
they would pick you up.
They would put you in
jail for three days.
And on the third day, they
would let you out and say,
you're lucky we didn't
find any info on you.
You get let out of
jail, sure, but you've
lost your job for not showing
up to work for three days.
Additionally, it was
harder to get a new job,
because when your new
prospective employer would
call the police department
and ask if you had a record,
they would show them
your permanent record
and it would say, he was picked
up on having committed a crime.
This practice largely
existed through the 1950s.
Over 40,000 people were
picked up in 1957 alone.
While this tactic was phased
out in the late 1950s,
the marks on the
criminal records
remained until the mid-1960s
and it took an entirely separate
effort to get those expunged.
Furthermore, in the mid-1960s,
Detroit's black community
was in a state of flux.
Given the urban
renewal that took place
in the 1950s and early
'60s, the black community
was suffering economically
and politically,
and despite comprising 30%
of the city's population,
they wield very little
political power.
One of the major
victories politically
for the black
community, actually,
was getting Jerome
Cavanagh elected in 1962.
So as I've mentioned,
Detroit is highly segregated,
staunchly defended, and this
didn't just happen overnight.
This was well-planned,
well-executed,
and decades in the making.
And Detroit is not alone.
Many other Northern cities
look exactly like this.
When much of the civil
rights legislation
was written in the 1960s, it
explicitly targeted the South
and ignored the North.
This is a demographics
map of Detroit from 1940.
Detroit, like the
rest of the country,
went through the Great
Depression during the 1930s.
But because the rumors
were still strong
that if you needed
a factory job,
you could get one in Detroit,
many, many people kept coming.
As a result, there was
a massive housing crisis
due to the lack of public
and private investment
in housing, due
to the Depression.
When people began arriving
in the city in droves,
they found farmland.
They found tents to sleep in.
They found alleyways,
potholes, wherever
they could lay their head.
It was far easier for
the white community
to find housing than
for the black community.
When the black community
arrived in Detroit,
the primary destination was
Black Bottom, Paradise Valley
in the North End.
There was another enclave
on the West Side, now called
the Old West Side.
But as the black community
grew economically
and demographically, they
found other pockets to fill in.
And each of these
other areas of the city
demonstrates a different
tactic that was
used to deny black mobility.
We had Conant Gardens
on the East Side
and Eight Mile Wyoming
on the West Side.
Two of the primary tactics
used to stop black mobility
were called restrictive
covenants and redlining.
Restrictive covenants
were legal maneuvers
written into deeds
that simply said
what race could buy a home.
The two primary targets
of restrictive covenants
in Detroit were
the black community
and the Jewish community,
but the Latino community
and the Asians community, they
were all targeted as well.
Eight Mile Wyoming popped
up because a group of urban
pioneers-- those were black
folks who want to live in white
areas in nicer housing--
found out that this
area was unrestricted.
So a group of them got up
and bought a bunch of homes
and settled the area,
founding a new neighborhood.
When World War II
began, and there was now
new funding and new
purpose for building homes,
100,000 housing units were
built on the West Side alone.
98,000 of those
were specifically
earmarked for the
white community only.
Only 2,000 of them were
open to people of color.
Luckily, enough the Eight
Mile Wyoming neighborhood
was already established.
When a real estate developer
showed up to the neighborhood
and saw the empty land
next to them, and said,
this would be a great place
to build a new subdivision.
Make a bunch of money.
It'd be a great day.
He goes to the Federal
Housing Authority.
The Federal Housing Authority
was responsible for handing out
mortgage insurance.
If you wanted to buy a
house, you needed a mortgage.
If you wanted a mortgage, you
needed mortgage insurance.
And this is where
redlining comes into play.
The Federal Housing Authority
had a color-coded system
for providing
mortgage insurance.
Green and blue were perfectly
fine, yellow was sketchy,
and red was a big no.
Red meant people of
color lived there.
Yellow meant people of
color lived next to them.
When he went to the
Federal Housing Authority,
they said no.
He said, why not?
Black people live there.
Don't worry, I'm not going
to sell to black people.
I'm going to sell
to white people.
Black people still live there.
What can I do?
I know, what if I built a wall?
He built a wall.
He built a half-mile long,
six-foot tall, one-foot thick
concrete wall called
the Birwood Wall.
That wall is still
standing today.
When the majority of the black
community came to Detroit,
they came to Hastings Street.
Hastings Street was
the main thoroughfare
of Black Bottom Paradise
Valley in the North End.
It was cram-packed with
businesses, dentists, doctors,
insurance companies, lawyers,
markets, haberdashers,
the whole nine yards.
If you needed something
you could get it
on Hastings Street.
The problem with
Hastings Street,
and what would be
a major problem
for the black
community, was just
because the black community
lived there, does not mean
the black community owned it.
Additionally,
Hastings Street was
one of the, if not
the most, [INAUDIBLE]
school neighborhood in the city.
It was one of the oldest.
it was full of
turn-of-the-century century
buildings.
If these buildings had
plumbing and electricity,
they were most
likely retrofitted.
We have oral histories
from Black Bottom which
said there were still outhouses
in the neighborhood going
into the 1940s.
That would become a major issue
for the black community going
into the 1940s and
into the 1950s.
To ease this housing crunch,
the federal government
stepped in and said, we need
a place for black war workers
to live, and public
housing is going
to be the way we're
going to do it.
Eleanor Roosevelt opened the
Brewster-Douglass project
herself.
And the third
project on the list
was the Sojourner
Truth housing project.
The federal
government believed it
was close enough to Conant
Gardens on the East Side not
to cause a stir.
They were mistaken.
It was seven blocks within a
white neighborhood at Seven
Mile and Fenelon, and the
residents, it's safe to say,
were super pissed.
They took this issue
to their congressman,
who went to the
floor of the House
to denounce the federal
government for moving
black people into
his neighborhood.
It became a massive tug-of-war
between the residents,
the city, and the
federal government
about what type of
project this would be,
whether it would be
black, white, or mixed.
During construction, it was
just a massive tug of war.
Finally, the federal government
put its foot down and said,
we need places for black
war workers to live
and that's the end of it.
As tenants were beginning to
move in to Sojourner Truth,
they were greeted by this sign.
Not only were they
greeted by this sign,
they were greeted by 1,200
very angry protesters.
A scuffle ensued, and the
Detroit Police Department
ordered all the
tenants to leave,
saying they couldn't
guarantee their protection.
The tenants would later be
moved in under the armed guard
of the Michigan National Guard.
Fully armed, machine guns,
the whole nine yards.
The Sojourner Truth
housing project
would be the site of drive-bys,
people driving by and shooting
into it, bricks through windows,
and the occasional burning
cross for the next few years.
We don't just leave our violence
behind at Sojourner Truth.
The city boiled over in
1943, in the 1943 race riots.
Preceding the 1943 race riot,
though, was the Packard strike.
The city is in the
midst of World War II.
We're pumping as much munitions
into the war effort as we can.
And one of those vital
factories is the Packard plant.
This is the Packard
Motor Car company.
What they're doing is,
they're making engines.
Given the fact that everyone
is needed for the war effort,
there is a massive
labor shortage still.
Packard's solution
was, hire black people
to do the same work.
Three black men were promoted
to the line at Packard,
and the next day 25,000
whites walked off the job.
Their placards
read, I'd rather see
Hitler or Hirohito win than
to work next to a black man.
And they weren't that
kind in their language.
The city boiled over into the
1943 race riot a short time
later.
There were over 100,000 people
on Belle Isle that Sunday,
and there were minor racial
skirmishes here and there,
but everyone went
home that night.
The best story we have
is, one of the young men
who was involved in
the skirmishes that day
went to the Forest
Club in Paradise Valley
and was chatting with
an acquaintance of his.
He was talking about
the goings-on of the day
and what had
happened on the Isle.
And then all of a sudden,
the gentleman stood up,
announced to the bar
that a group of white men
threw a black woman and her
baby off the Belle Isle Bridge.
The bar patrons didn't take
too kindly to hearing that,
so a group of them went over
to the Belle Isle Bridge,
where a fight ensued with a
group of military recruits.
While that's going
on, another rumor
is spreading around
the white community
that a group of black men
assaulted a white woman
downtown.
The two rumors and
the scuffles meet,
and it is brawling
in the streets.
It is two days of violence
and hand-to-hand combat.
The violence tended
to break down
with the black community
targeting property, either
through fire, just
damage, or looting,
while the white
community targeted
the black community itself.
And that is reflected
in the death toll,
through cold-blooded
murder, beatings, maulings,
the whole nine yards.
It took 6,000 federal troops
to come in and put it down.
Eleanor Roosevelt urged
her husband, the president,
to do a Fireside Chat
on race relations
to move the issue forward.
Let's get over this.
President Roosevelt
declined in favor
of getting war
production back on track,
because war production fell 6%.
We have a few stories from '43
that aren't totally terrible.
First one is this
photo right here.
We have a Detroit police officer
protecting a young black man
from an angry mob.
I would love to say that this
is standard operating procedure,
but unfortunately, it wasn't.
The Detroit Police
Department was actually
dressed down pretty aggressively
by the federal troops who
came into town and saw how
they were acting, especially
towards the black community.
I had the pleasure
of interviewing
a woman who was there that day.
And for work, what
she would do is,
she would pick up all the
bills along Hastings Street
from the businesses, and
take them down to City Hall
to pay them all.
So she collected the bills.
Someone said, what
are you doing?
She said, I'm going
to go pay these.
They were like, that's
a terrible idea.
She's like, you
know I'll be fine.
So she hops on the
Woodward streetcar
and starts heading downtown.
The only other person
on the streetcar
is an elderly white woman.
They look ahead.
They're seeing something
but can't quite
make out what it is.
It is a massive white mob.
What white mobs have been
doing during this time,
have been going up
and down Woodward,
pulling black people out of
bars, cars, streetcars, buses,
and beating them.
The white woman looks
at her and says,
I think you should
get under my chair.
I don't know what
they're going to do.
So she crawls under a chair,
they cover her up with bags.
Mob storms the street car.
They look around.
Are you the only one here?
Yup.
Fine.
And they exit the streetcar
and the woman's protected.
We leave a lot of the
violence behind in the 1940s,
but we have a brand
new plethora of issues.
We see the making of modern
Detroit in the 1950s,
through mass
deindustrialization,
through white flight
and blockbusting,
and furthering all
of this is City Hall.
City Hall at the time is run
by Mayor Albert Cobo, who
ran an explicit
campaign of stopping
the black invasion of
Detroit, and his policies
do not do anything to either
mend or improve the situation.
Restrictive covenants are
ruled unconstitutional in 1948,
and as a result, we see the
explosion of homeowners'
associations across Detroit.
A homeowners' association
called the Seven Mile Fenelon
Homeowners' Association was
responsible for putting up
the sign I showed you earlier,
and their presence in the city
only grew from there.
Homeowners'
associations would have
said that they're only there
to protect home equity,
to protect your investment.
If you asked them how
they are doing it,
they were keeping black people
out of the neighborhood.
In the South, I'm
sure many of you
have heard of White
Citizens' Councils.
They were our White
Throughout the 1950s, we see
the prevalence of the big four.
Investigative arrests explode.
And then we see
neighborhood destruction
and the cementing
of modern Detroit
for freeway construction.
Many people won't really
associate this quote with 1961,
but Detroit's decline has been
going on for a long while.
"Time" magazine said it,
and with good reason.
Between 1952 and
1960, Detroit lost
23.4% of the white community
to the suburbs and elsewhere,
the majority to the suburbs.
That number is baffling
to some, but is actually
really easy to explain.
A number of things are happening
in Detroit all at once.
Detroit was facing mass
deindustrialization,
like it had never
experienced before.
After World War II, the Big
Three built 19 new plants,
and those were not in
the city of Detroit.
They were in the suburbs and
other satellite communities.
They did that for a number of
really good economic reasons.
You didn't need to tear
down your old factory
to build a new one.
You could get away
with lesser taxes,
because the suburbs were not
nearly as strong as the city.
They were changing the way
factories were being built.
They were no longer
tall, multi-story plants.
They were large,
single-story facilities,
which meant you
didn't need to buy out
homeowners that were
living across the street
from your factory.
And additionally, the
federal government
wanted have the majority of
the plants out of Detroit
immediately.
The federal
government didn't want
one nuclear bomb taking out 10%
of the nation's manufacturing
base.
As a result, spreading it out
was much safer for the nation,
but not for Detroit.
As these plants are
moving out of the city,
the white community
is following,
because a lot of
people don't want
to drive 40 minutes to work.
As a result, the
white community begins
diminishing very quickly.
But as you can see, the black
community continues to grow.
That is because
the black community
didn't have the same avenues
of getting to the suburbs
that the white community did.
In order to move to the
suburbs, you needed a house.
In order to get a house,
you had to have a mortgage.
You had to get a mortgage
to buy one or to build one,
and to do that, you
needed mortgage insurance,
and the black community
still did not have access
to mortgage insurance en masse.
Even going into 1970, the
suburban population of color
stood at only 3.6%.
While the factories are moving
out, other factories are dying.
Packard and Hudson Motor Car
Companies go out of business.
They go bankrupt due to the
rolling recessions in the '50s,
and 90,000 jobs were lost on the
East Side in two years alone.
Between 1947 and
1967, Detroit loses
47% of its manufacturing base.
What you see here is a flyer
from the West Side Home
and Property Owners'
Protective Association,
arguing that if the freeways
are built as they're proposed,
your property values are
going to be destroyed
and drastic change
will come to the city.
And they are arguing
that because they
are partially right.
Not on the property
values thing,
but drastic change was coming.
Unlike other major cities,
where they used freeways
to divide races,
Detroit initially
seemingly tried to
use them to integrate.
Instead of putting them
between two neighborhoods,
Detroit put its freeway
right up the middle
of the black community.
That picture I
showed you earlier
of Hastings Street, most
of you have probably
driven on Hastings Street.
It's the I-75 freeway.
Hastings Street is gone,
wiped away, along with all
of its businesses and much
of the black community's
economic might.
Black Bottom is
demolished to make room
for Lafayette Park, which
I'm sure many of you
have also seen.
The city and national officials
touted it as urban renewal.
We're cleaning up
the inner city.
We're going to make it great
for everyone living here.
It's gong to be
a grand old time.
People being evicted
simply referred to it
as negro removal.
Additionally, this outpouring,
this seeming mass migration
of refugees from the
three neighborhoods
sparked a great deal
of fear and uncertainty
in the rest of the city.
Primarily just the
rest of the city,
because the black community
didn't have the means of moving
to the suburbs.
So as the black community
began spreading across Detroit,
many segregationist whites
and many uncertain whites
simply begin moving either to
the farther edges of the city
or moving out altogether.
One tactic that was
used during this,
much to the detriment of the
city, was called blockbusting.
What blockbusting was,
was a real estate agent
would either hire a
young black mother
with a toddler in a stroller,
burly black men in larger cars,
or groups of black teens
and young kids with bikes.
What they would do is, they
would have the mother walk down
the street.
They'd have the men drive
down the street slowly,
with their stereos cranked up.
Or they'd have the kids
ride around the neighborhood
on their bikes.
They'd wait a day or
two, and then they
would call every
house on the block.
They're like, hey, we've got
this great new development
in Royal Oak that you
should totally check out.
And because it was a
common belief at the time
that if a black person
moved into your neighborhood
you just lost $15,000
on your house,
so many people would sell
low and get out before they
lost any more money.
And then the real estate agent
would simply flip the house,
often to a
unsuspecting person who
couldn't make the payments
in the first place,
and the cycle would
repeat itself,
destroying Detroit's property
values all across the city.
And for many people, this
was an easy decision to make,
because the freeways
that are now
brand-new allow easy access
to and from the suburbs.
This is the area that
was torn down to make way
for the I-75 freeway.
As you can see, the
freeway makes up
a very tiny portion of it.
The periphery of the
freeway was also torn down
to make room for development.
The problem was,
in the early '60s,
there was no money
for development,
so the land sat empty for years.
One of the places that
the black community went,
after Black Bottom
and Paradise Valley,
was the Virginia Park
neighborhood on the West Side.
The Virginia Park neighborhood
was a Jewish neighborhood.
It was far easier
for black folks
to move into Jewish
neighborhoods
than Christian neighborhoods,
because the Jewish community
faced a great deal of
the same discrimination
that the black
community dealt with.
You can actually
watch Jewish migration
follow hand-in-hand
with black migration.
If you look at the demographics,
it's really interesting.
12th Street was already a
vibrant business district,
but was only amplified with
the arrival of black merchants.
It had everything you
could possibly need.
There was a saying that if
you needed anything legal,
you could get it
there during the day.
Also, if you needed
anything illegal,
you could probably
get it there at night.
It was also the home of clubs,
vice, gambling, prostitution,
and as a result, it garnered
a very seedy reputation
in the ranks of the
Detroit Police Department.
Which leads us to '67.
On July 23, the Detroit
Police Department
initiated a routine
raid on a blind pig
near the corner of
12th and Clairmount
in the Virginia
Park neighborhood.
There is a great
deal to unpack here.
Blind pigs were illegal
after-hours clubs
in the city of Detroit,
both in the white
and the black neighborhoods.
They were illegal
for two reasons.
They didn't have
a liquor license
and they operated after 2:00 AM.
Many workers in the city, if
they worked the afternoon shift
at the factories, got off
about midnight, 1:00 AM.
As a result, they wanted to
go relax with their friends
and couldn't do it if
the bars closed at 2:00.
Blind pigs were prevalent
all across the city.
This one just happened to be
in the black neighborhood.
When the police arrived
and scouted it out,
they expected to
find 10 to 15 people.
This was routine and easy
work for the Detroit Police
Department.
What they would do is,
they'd bust in the door,
arrest everyone,
charge them $27.50.
People would pay it right
away, and then the people
would probably go back
drinking that same night.
This night didn't go as planned.
What happened was, when
they raided the blind pig,
they found 83 people in
a space meant for 40.
They stumbled upon a party
for two Vietnam vets.
As a result of the
size of the group
and how few officers
there were, the arrests
didn't go as planned.
They only had one paddy wagon
available to ferry people
to the 10th Precinct,
so it took over an hour
to get everyone out of there.
That caused a great
deal of issues.
Soon there were more
people on 12th Street
than police across
the entire city.
You're probably
asking yourself, why
were so many people on the
street at 3 o'clock, now
4 o'clock in the morning?
It was insanely warm.
This was before
air conditioning.
This is a very densely
populated area.
If you didn't want to
be sweating in your bed,
you were walking around because
it was cooler to be outside.
And if you were sweating in your
bed, you had your windows open,
and you could hear the
commotion really early on.
And given that this was the
time before cell phones,
it was better to see
something for yourself
than to wait for something
to pounce on you.
As the final arrestees
were loaded up
and the police cruisers
began driving away,
a bottle is thrown
by William Scott III
and shatters the back
window of a police cruiser,
and the uprising begins.
It's important to note that,
while '67 was spontaneous,
there were
longstanding grievances
that fueled it and maintained
it for the relatively five days
that it lasted.
Much of the grievances can be
filed into three categories,
predatory business owners,
disingenuous landlords,
and continued terrible
police-community relations.
We have many stories from
terrible business owners
in the inner city neighborhoods.
I interviewed two
Wayne State students
who spent their free time
going to different A&P markets
in the inner city
and checking the food
to make sure it was good still.
They routinely found moldy
vegetables, moldy fruit,
expired baby formula.
Additionally, I
interviewed a principal
who was principal of Hutchins
Middle School in Virginia Park.
Someone had recently stolen
all of their musical equipment,
and one of the kids tracked
it down to a pawn shop.
As they were pulling
up, the principal said,
as we were going in the front,
we saw a giant white van drive
out from the back and all
the instruments were gone.
When he came back from
vacation after '67,
he said, that pawn
shop was burned down.
I'm pretty sure I know
the kid that did it,
and I would have been
standing next to him
if I would have been home.
If you were a person
of color in Detroit
during the '50s and
'60s, it was well
known that you would
pay $50 for a $40 house
in a $30 neighborhood.
And we're not talking about a
posh apartment with great views
of the river, either.
These are subdivided homes.
These are older apartments that
don't offer the same amenities
as today.
Additionally, it was
more expensive to live
in a subdivided home
in the inner city
than to have a brand new
house all to yourself
on the West Side.
And while '67 may
seem widespread,
as it touched many
parts of the city,
only a small
percentage of the city
was engaged in
what was going on,
and many honest store
owners and citizens
got caught in the middle
and lost everything.
The Detroit Police
Department were
engaged from the beginning,
along with the Detroit Fire
Department.
There were 4,700 Detroit
police officers, 1,200 Detroit
firemen.
The Michigan State Police and
the Michigan National Guard
joined Sunday afternoon.
1,100 Michigan State
Police came to town.
7,000 Michigan National
Guardsmen came into the city.
And on Tuesday morning,
5,000 federal troops
entered the city.
I mentioned earlier that
the crowd grew faster
than the police presence did.
That was not a hard
milestone to meet.
The police department was at
its lowest amount of officers
during the week during this
period, and there are only 200
on duty out of 4,700.
It was a hot weekend
in July and a whole lot
of people left to go
fishing, pretty much, which
caused a very chaotic
situation to unfold with trying
to deal with the situation.
As the Detroit Police
Department attempted
to formulate a
response, civic leaders
were going into the
community in an attempt
to get people to go home.
Freshly elected Congressman
John Conyers and Arthur
Johnson, head of the NAACP in
Detroit, go to 12th Street,
they stand on the top
of Art Johnson's car,
and they beg and plead
folks to go home.
They said, we're going
to make this right.
It's going to work.
They were actually
shouted down and pelted
with whatever people could
find, and they get out of there.
John Conyers would
later say he didn't even
think that Malcolm X could have
gotten those people to go home.
While they're doing that,
local pastors are organizing
in an attempt to get
people to go home,
and Mayor Cavanagh
and not-yet-judge,
but soon-to-be Judge
Damon J. Keith,
are calling every radio station,
every television station,
every newspaper,
anyone who talks
to the public en masse,
and telling them,
do not say the word riot.
Don't talk about the smoke.
Don't talk about fires.
Just say, hey, today is
a great day to go home.
Everyone should just go home
and just stay in their house.
They're also calling preachers
and asking them to slip
that in their sermon as well.
After '67, they would
also ask preachers
to slip into their sermon,
if you stole anything,
drop it off at night and
you won't get in trouble.
So as this is going on, the
Detroit Police Department
is assembling some
of its officers back
and they attempt to
essentially retake
Virginia Park, because
police and firemen withdraw
from the area because they
can't formulate a response.
As the police go to sweep the
streets in this formation right
here, their crowd control fell
apart in roughly 20 minutes.
And that's from the
Special Assistant
to the Police Commissioner.
What happened was,
when the police
would line up to
sweep the streets,
they didn't have anyone
to cover the side streets.
So the crowd would
split in half,
they would run
down the alleyways,
and get right back
up behind them,
making crowd control
seemingly impossible.
When the National
Guard came to town,
they not only came to town with
no formal training whatsoever
in how to handle
this, but many of them
had not experienced two
things before in their lives.
But first, the training.
That's a big claim to make, and
I have evidence to back it up.
We have an interview with a man
who was with the Michigan Air
National Guard,
and his job was, he
was a clerk at Metro Airport.
He would drive to Metro
Airport every weekend,
push papers for them,
and then go home.
That Sunday, he arrived at
Metro Airport to push papers,
and the commanding officer
came into the office, ordered
everyone down onto the tarmac.
They taught them how
to march for two hours,
gave them guns, and shipped
them downtown, without bullets.
We have other stories of
other National Guardsmen
who were trained how
to fight the Soviets,
not patrol the
streets of Detroit.
Further complicating the
no-training-for-this was
the fact that many National
Guardsmen were from western
and northern rural Michigan.
Many had not seen a building
taller than six stories,
let alone more than one next
to each other, and many of them
had not seen a
black person before.
They came into town
with nothing but fear
and stereotypes, which I
can say did not lend itself
well to the situation.
And complicating everything
is politics, because why not?
Bottom right is Mayor
Jerome Cavanagh, Democrat.
Middle is Governor
George Romney, father
of Mitt Romney, Republican.
And top left is President
Lyndon Johnson, Democrat.
This is before
the 1968 election.
Johnson has not yet announced
he will not seek re-election,
or maybe he hasn't decided yet.
Romney has announced
that he will
be seeking the Republican
nomination for president.
And Cavanagh is being touted as
a possible primary challenger
to Johnson, because Johnson
is incredibly unpopular due
to the Vietnam War.
And Johnson knows all of that.
Very quickly, Cavanagh begins
clamoring for state aid,
because the police
department can't handle it.
Romney is more than
happy to come to town
because he wants this
as a feather in his cap
when he runs as the
law-and-order candidate in '68,
which is what Richard
Nixon will do.
Very quickly, it becomes evident
that the National Guard can't
handle the situation,
and Cavanagh
begins clamoring for
federal intervention.
Johnson and Romney both
don't want to do that.
Romney doesn't want him to do it
because that would mean Johnson
stealing his
victory, and Johnson
doesn't want to do it
because Romney and Cavanagh's
political careers are burning
down with the city of Detroit.
Eventually, Romney agrees
and sends a telegram
to Johnson recommending
the use of federal troops
in the city of Detroit.
Johnson sends a
telegram back saying,
you do not recommended
to the president.
He sends another one requesting
the use of federal troops
in the city of Detroit, and
he agrees to it technically.
5,000 troops are sent
to Selfridge Air Force
Base as part of
Task Force Detroit,
and they were sent to
Selfridge Air Force Base,
20 miles outside the city
limits of Detroit, where
they're not allowed to leave.
Only two officials come to
the city, Gen. Throckmorton
and Cyrus Vance, who patrol
the city Monday night with city
officials and Romney--
well, Monday afternoon.
And they see nothing.
They don't see fires,
they don't see looting.
They got a flat tire.
That was about it.
They announced
that, we missed it.
Sorry, guys, we came so late.
The situation seemed
to be under control.
Cavanagh is freaking out.
He's like, it's not over.
This happened last night.
It's a lull.
I promise you it's
going to get worse.
Romney is pretty pleased.
He's like, thank
you guys for coming.
We have the situation handled.
It's all good.
They announce the federal
government will not
be stepping in, federal troops
will be leaving again soon.
And Monday night is the
worst night of the uprising.
Soon, they change their
tune, and federal troops
take over the East Side on
Tuesday morning, about 2:00 AM.
While the city is
calming down, we
have one of the,
if not the worst,
incidents of the uprising, the
Algiers Motel Incident and/or
the Algiers Motel Massacre.
Wednesday morning,
there are reports
of sniper fire coming from
near the area of the Algiers.
A National Guard unit, a
Michigan State Police unit,
three Detroit police officers,
a black security guard,
and two military M.P.s
converge on the Algiers,
believing it to be the
source of the sniper fire.
The Detroit Police Department
are the first ones in the door.
And this is where multiple
stories start to emerge,
but the best information
we have is this.
They find Carl Cooper coming
either down the stairs
or around from the stairs, and
they shoot him in the chest,
killing him.
Next, they find Fred Temple on
the phone with his girlfriend,
and they shoot him in the chest.
They finish sweeping the rest
of the first floor, then order
everyone to come downstairs.
They line everyone
up against the wall.
Left are two white women
and seven black men.
They begin beating and
berating those along the wall.
The Detroit Police Department
are leading the effort.
They specifically target the two
white women, repeatedly asking
them, why aren't white
men good enough for you?
Why are you cavorting
with black men?
What are you doing?
They would strip
them and beat them.
This is when the military
M.P.s left and, quote,
"Things took an ugly turn."
The last thing a
military M.P. saw
was a Detroit police
officer holding
a shotgun between a man's
legs and threatening
to blow his balls off.
Next up, the
Michigan State Police
go out to their commanding
officer and say,
the Detroit Police Department
is committing civil rights
violations.
They're beating those people.
What do we do?
The commanding
officer says, that
sounds like a Detroit
Police Department problem.
And they all leave.
Left are the three
Detroit police officers,
led by Officer Senak, and
the National Guard unit,
and the black security guard.
And this is when the
execution game begins.
Senak pulls a man into a side
room and pretends to shoot him.
When he comes out,
he says, this is
what happens when you don't
tell me where the gun is.
He should have cooperated.
He winks at the leader of
the National Guard, who
takes another man into a side
room and pretends to shoot him.
Officer Senak then
asks Officer Paille
if he feels like
shooting anybody today.
Officer Paille grabs
a man off the wall,
throws him into a side room--
throws him into the same room
as a now-dying Fred Temple,
and he shoots Aubrey Pollard
in the chest, killing him.
All this takes place
within roughly 30 minutes.
The National Guard take
the two white women away
and the rest of the men
are ordered to leave.
This is successfully covered
up for about five days.
The three men are listed
as riot-related casualties.
It's said that they got into
a firefight with each other
and killed each other.
That is called in by the
clerk of the motel, as ruled
by the Wayne County coroner.
The families reject
this immediately.
They think it's one of the most
foolish things they've ever
heard.
They are able to sneak
back into the Algiers,
take their own photographs,
do their own investigation.
The "News" breaks the
story and the "Free Press"
carries it home.
Soon, two of the officers
confess to what they did,
Officer Paille and
Officer August.
And Senak is about to
confess before his confession
is interrupted by
his defense attorney.
Those two officers are brought
up on charges in Detroit
and acquitted.
The three Detroit police
officers and the black security
guard are brought up
on federal charges
and the trial is moved to
all-white Mason, Michigan,
where another all-white
jury acquits all four men.
The Detroit police were
racist, the National Guard
didn't know what
they were doing,
and the federal
troops put it down.
I heard this more than once,
conducting the oral history
project and doing my own
independent research.
It holds up fairly well.
Officially, 43
dead, nearly 1,200
injured, over 7,200 arrested,
and as you can probably guess,
there aren't that many jail
cells in the city of Detroit,
nor are there that many
in southeastern Michigan.
Arrestees were picked up for
not only looting and arson
and stuff like that,
but the majority of them
were picked up for
a curfew violation.
If you were out past
9:00 or out before 5:00,
you were most likely
rounded up en masse
and arrested as
quickly as possible
to get you off the street.
Many people who
were arrested were
thrown in makeshift
facilities and packed in there
as tightly as possible.
They were put in basements,
they were put in garages,
they were put in cages,
they were put in buses.
Belle Isle became a
major holding facility
later in the week, and it
was nicknamed Bellecatraz.
And the conditions were not
very favorable to them at all.
I interviewed one man who was
kept in the garage for a day,
and the only fresh air they
got when someone mouthed off
to the police and they closed
the doors, was they were given
a hose to flush the drain they
were all going to the bathroom
in.
They would take that hose
and they would hold it up
to their nose so they could
breathe the fresh air that
was coming out with the water.
One of the major
things people point
to is increased white flight--
was white flight beginning
in '67, but it
increased for sure.
And the proliferation of
firearms across the city
was a major, major
moment for the city.
There were more handguns sold
in the first six months of 1968
than the entire year of 1967.
That masks the real
number of guns sold,
because it was far easier
to buy guns in Toledo
than it was in Detroit.
So many people would simply
drive the 45 minutes down
to Toledo, buy their
guns, and come back.
The, same is true for long guns
such as rifles and shotguns
as well.
There are many myths
and misconceptions
that surround '67.
That's part of the
reason we really
wanted to do this project.
In terms of looting,
many people immediately
believe or assume that the
black community were the looters
during '67.
Looting was highly integrated.
Hubert Locke, who was the
Special Assistant to the Police
Commissioner, would
say in his oral history
that he thinks '67 was one
of the most integrated things
Detroit has ever done.
One of the first things
he saw was a picture
of two white guys and two
black eyes running past him
with a couch.
He's like, that's new.
Additionally, pawn shops played
a really interesting role
in the spread of looting.
The activist General Baker
talks about how pawning
was the central pillar of
his community's economy
at the time.
And on the back of
every pawn slip,
it would say, "Will not
replace in case of fire, theft,
or flood."
So a bunch of his
neighbors looked at them,
and would say to
each other, well,
if someone's going to steal
my stuff, it's going to be me.
And pawn shops were, in fact,
some of the first places hit,
because many residents were
running in, stealing their item
back, and going home.
But seeing 40 people rush
into a store, especially
multiple stores, doesn't really
bode well for the situation.
Additionally, we have
anecdotal evidence--
we don't have any
hard evidence yet--
of interstate looters.
I interviewed one man by the
name of John Eddings, who
lived off of
Linwood at the time,
and as he was
driving over Linwood,
he looked down the street.
He had never seen so
many out-of-state license
plates in his life.
Ohio, Illinois, Indiana were all
represented at noon on Sunday.
Additionally, we have
another story from a man
by the name of
Richard Rybinski, who
lived in Midtown at the time.
And he was like, I'm tired
of listening to the radio.
I really got to figure out
what's going on for myself.
So he hops on his
bike and starts
riding around the neighborhood.
One of the times
he's riding around,
he's standing at
a street corner,
and a station wagon pulls
up with a trailer attached,
an Ohio license
plate on the front,
and two old white guys
in the seats, asking,
where's the looting at?
I'm sure many of you have
seen videos from '67,
and the fire sticks
out pretty prevalently.
We have stories of those
fires being intentionally set
for insurance money.
The problem was, if you
burned down one building,
you would most likely
burn down a strip.
And if you burned
down that strip,
you'd most likely burn down the
residential areas behind it.
Detroit was built
incredibly packed in,
and it was very
warm and very dry.
The wind was so strong that
it would often carry fire
over a building to hit another.
That's why if
you're ever looking,
and you're like, how did
that one house in the middle
survive?
It's because the wind literally
picked it up and brought it
over.
Furthermore, fire was
not the only major cause
of damage in the city.
Bullets were.
In five days, the
Michigan National Guard
shot off 155,000 rounds.
That number always blew my mind.
I was like, how
is that possible?
In speaking with a man who
trained with the National
Guard, the tactic at the time
was, if someone shoots at you,
80% of the people
you're with begin
shooting in that general
vicinity, and the other 20%
move to flank.
So if you got shot
at, you're unleashing
dozens, if not hundreds, of
bullets in the general area,
inflicting great deal of damage.
Additionally, the favorite
target of National Guardsmen
were street lights.
It was believed that if
a sniper could see you,
a sniper could shoot you.
So they would shoot
out the street lights
where they were
stationed and where
they were patrolling
Grand River, Woodward,
Jefferson all had their
street lights shot out.
And where they were stationed
were civic buildings.
They were stationed at parks,
schools, other government
buildings, civic centers, that
all had their floodlights shot
out as well, and they
certainly didn't replace them
when they left.
That same principal I mentioned
earlier, so when he came home,
he went straight to the school.
He looked up, he
said, not only were
all my floodlights shot up,
but my building was shot up,
because they couldn't
hit the damn floodlights.
Sniping, in regards to '67,
is incredibly confusing.
Sniping is misleading.
We have a lot of
shooters in '67.
Snipers are good shots.
The primary target of those
shooters were fire trucks.
So when the firemen
would pull up,
they'd start shooting
at the truck,
and the firemen would leave.
So the question is, why
were they doing that?
Were they simply trying to stop
people from authorities from
coming back into
the neighborhood?
Were they trying to stop
that fire from being put out?
We don't know.
I haven't met one.
I would love to speak
with a sniper just
to get their motivation down.
Additionally, the majority of
people arrested for sniping
were white.
And then the biggest myth
or misconception of all
is that white flight
started in '67
and the city was hunky
dory before that.
Throughout this presentation,
I have used the term uprising.
That is a conscious decision.
There are four main terms used
to describe what took place.
Uprising, riot, rebellion,
and civil unrest/disturbance.
Riot is primarily used by the
white community, suburbanites,
and political conservatives.
It focuses on the
spontaneity of what
happened, the criminality
of what took place, and lays
the majority of
the blame for what
happened at the feet
of the black community.
Rebellion is primarily used
by the black community,
Detroiters, and
political progressives.
It focuses not so much
on the spontaneity,
but the reasons
and the historical
grievances that fueled it.
It sidesteps the
damage and pushback
as part of the
righteous struggle,
and also lays the
majority of the blame
at the feet of the white
community for allowing
the conditions to persist long
enough to spark such an event.
Uprising is an
amalgam of the two.
It says, while it
was spontaneous,
it was fueled by longstanding
grievances that permeated
through the community.
It accepts that in
violent uprisings,
criminality and damage
happens, but it also divvies up
the blame for not only what took
place, but how it played out.
And that usually depends on
whoever you're talking to
at that particular moment.
Civil disturbance is used
by usually people who
aren't trying to take a side,
just like journalists or news
anchors, or people who are just
trying to make a quick point
and then move on.
There are problems
with all of them.
People who use the term riot
don't like the term uprising
or rebellion
because they believe
it lets criminals off the
hook, and allows lazy people
to continue to be lazy.
People who use the term
rebellion don't like the term
uprising, because
they believe it
dilutes the black
community's right to rebel.
So many people find
problems with these terms.
But as long as we understand
the perspective that
leads to each term, it allows
for much greater conversation.
Insurrection,
revolution, and war
were also used during
this week, and also
used to describe this week.
At the bottom, race
riot is grayed out.
We at the Detroit
Historical Society
do not believe what took
place in '67 was a race riot.
It wasn't, get that police
officer, he's white.
It's, get that
police officer, he's
been beating me up for 20 years.
It wasn't, get that
store owner, he's white.
It's, get that store owner,
he helped sell my instruments
that were stolen.
Stuff like that.
It was far more
anti-authoritarian,
and anti-authority,
than based on race.
It's important for us to be able
to frame and conceptualize '67,
because other people
are doing it for us.
"Life" magazine called it
a revolt. "Time" magazine
called it a riot.
Kathryn Bigelow called it a war.
So, it doesn't really matter if
we have different perspectives
on it, as long as the
we have the ability
to understand the various
perspectives that surround '67.
For all the the
destructive things
that came about in '67, for
all the destructive things that
came about because of '67,
many constructive things
happened as well.
Detroit has always been
an activist town and that
didn't change with '67.
There are a huge
number of organizations
that stepped up to the
plate and organized in order
to help bring the city
back from seemingly
the brink of the abyss.
At the institutional
level, there
was New Detroit and Focus HOPE.
Also, the election of
Coleman Young in 1974
did a great deal for the city.
And that's really all I usually
say about Coleman Young,
because in this town, you
either love Coleman Young
or you hate Coleman Young,
and everyone will grandstand
till the end of time itself.
But grassroots activism
was where it's at.
Ad-Hoc Detroit was
founded by Sheila Cockrell
as an anti-police
brutality group.
People Against Racism was
founded by Frank Joyce,
and was an anti-racist,
anti-war-in-Vietnam group.
The League of
Revolutionary Black Workers
was our Black Panther Party.
It originally began as the Dodge
Revolutionary Union Movement,
which sought to get supervisory
positions and better paying
positions at the Dodge
main plant in Hamtramck,
but really branched out
into the social sphere
with youth groups,
and career training,
and other positive
community benefits.
One of those programs that
came out from unification
called the Motor
City Labor League,
was the Conflict,
Control, Change Book Club.
It was a group that
sought to socialize
white progressives to the
black radical perspective.
Basically, you want to know
why we're mad, read this book
and we'll talk about it.
They constantly had to find
new spaces because they
kept growing and growing and
growing, and at their peak,
they had about 350
members, active members.
The City-Wide Citizen's
Action Committee,
and the Inner-City
Business Improvement Forum
were other black
nationalist groups
that really sought to
rebuild the black community's
economy through co-ops and
other economic initiatives.
They were rather successful
till the recessions in the 1970s
hurt them pretty badly.
And fighting all of these
folks at once was Breakthrough.
Raise your hand if you know
Don Lobsinger, know the name
Don Lobsinger.
Don Lobsinger was a
right-wing activist
who is still very mad today.
He got his start
in the early 1960s.
He got a name for himself
for dropping dead rats
on the Chinese ping-pong
team at [INAUDIBLE],,
for interrupting
the Soviet Symphony,
for threatening to hang
seemingly everyone.
But his big break came in
1968 when, because of him,
the Grosse Pointe
Chief of Police
had to sit on Martin Luther
King, Jr.'s, lap on the way
to the Grosse Pointe
speech, and away
from the Grosse Pointe speech.
He was able to sneak
in and denounce King
as a traitor and a Communist.
We get asked multiple times,
why are we doing this project?
Our Project Director
was asked, why
pick a scab off an old wound?
He replied with, what makes
you think the scab ever formed?
There are many people in Detroit
who still talk about '67,
and that is because
'67 continues
to affect our daily lives.
And affects city
civil relations.
It affects race relations.
And as long as we
continue to talk about '67
in our tight little
silos, the conversation's
going to go nowhere.
So hopefully,
through this project,
we're going to be breaking
down those silos, which
allows us to have greater
conversations and more
meaningful conversations.
To do this, we put together
the Detroit '67 Project.
The first initiative we did was
launch the Detroit 1967 Oral
History Project, which
to date has collected
over 500 perspectives from '67.
That has fueled our community
engagement initiative,
which to date has over
100 formal partners and 50
informal partners.
Because we knew we only had
a limited amount of space
in our exhibit,
we've put together
the Detroit 1967 companion book,
"Detroit 1967-Origins, Impacts,
Legacies," which is
really the best Detroit
historians all in a tight
little book, plus me.
Danielle McGuire, Kevin Boyle,
Ken Coleman, Tom Sugrue,
Roy Finkenbine, really
Detroit's premier historians
dissecting the problems
that led to '67
and present them in a
compact, and relatable,
and easy-to-read way.
Promise that.
And the final step was unveiling
our exhibit at the Detroit
Historical Museum,
called "Detroit
'67-Perspectives," which
focuses on 1917 to the present,
and really lays out and
fleshes out the story of '67.
Here's some of our
academic partners.
Here's some people
who gave us money.
And these are
different exhibits that
also went on across the
city during the last year.
We are the only one
that is still up.
But this shows the commitment
that the cultural community
put forth in
understanding, dissecting,
and talking about '67.
And thank you so much Google.
It was great.
I probably said,
"Uh," like, a lot.
But other than
that, it was great.
[APPLAUSE]